kommt euch das bekannt vor man hat sich
irgendwie verrannt in eine skorile Idee
trifft eine
Entscheidung auch wenn man noch nicht so
genau weiß wie es gehen soll aber denkt
Mensch komm das ziehen wir jetzt durch
beim brexit ging das so um die meisten
Briten davon zu überzeugen brauchte es
populistische Strategien wie aus dem
Lehrbuch erstens erfinde einen Gegner
zweitens Lügen lohnt sich drittens werde
immer radikaler mein Name ist Hilke
Petersen ich leite seit einem Jahr das
ZDF auslandsstudio in London und wundere
mich wie sehr der brexit das Land und
die Leute quält noch immer 7 Jahre nach
der umkämpften
Abstimmung diese Fotos hier habe ich im
Oktober gemacht auf dem Parteitag der
konservativen Tories in Manchester am
Rande hil brexit Initiator nigel Farage
Hof umringt und bewundert von lauter
jungen Tories der Mann ist eindeutig ihr
Idol arbeitet inzwischen als
Fernsehmoderator bei einem konservativen
Privatsender er war da um vom Tor
Parteitag zu berichten über 20 Jahre hat
er im Europaparlament gesessen bis 2020
da war anderen auch schon aufgefallen
dass er mit fragwürdigen Argumenten den
Ausstieg Großbritanniens aus der EU
betrieb er hat mit seinen Verbündeten
das Land so tief gespalten wie wohl kein
Politiker vor ihm und nennt den brexit
von heute gescheitert den hatte er sich
nämlich anders
vorgestellt machte Kampagne auf der
Themse das war im Sommer 2016 kurz vor
der Abstimmung über den euaustritt
erfderte endlich die britische Kontrolle
über britische Gewässer von der EU
zurückzuholen neun von zehn Fischern
glaubten das dann damals auch was
Kontrolle über britische Gewässer genau
bedeuten würde das haben sie seiner Zeit
noch nicht verstanden kein Wunder kaum
etwas ist so kompliziert wie
Fischfangquoten hier greift
populismusprinzip ein geh hart gegen
deinen Gegner vor packe die Menschen bei
dem was Ihnen lieb und teuer ist die
Briten am besten am großen
Nationalgefühl Farage also zielte nicht
nur auf die britische Identität als
Fischer und seefahrerernation er meinte
auch Fischer und Chips ein kulinarisches
britisches
Nationalheiligtum der schelfisch lie FIS
vonage den er später auch werbewirksam
überbord in die temse kippte findet sich
in der Panade des nationalgerichts Fisch
und
Chips im Vereinigten Königreich gibt es
gut 10000 FIS und Chips Shops die Briten
Essen
322 Millionen Portionen pro Jahr wie
diese jeder und jeder also statistisch
mindestens alle zwei Monate eine all das
GT es zu retten aus den Fängen der
EU
was verage nicht sagte schon Jahrzehnte
zuvor seit den 70er Jahren hatten
britische Regierungen erlaubt dass etwa
die Hälfte der Fangquoten an
ausländische flotten verkauft wurden der
Abstieg der britischen Fischindustrie
hatte also begonnen längst bevor es
europäische Regeln gab wer wo wie viel
Fischen darf das hat die Vorbehalte der
Fischer gegen ausländische Konkurrenz
dann nur noch weiter befeuert die EU und
die Sache mit dem Fisch also schien eine
der wichtigsten brexit Angelegenheiten
zu sein und ich muss es jetzt mal ein
wenig ankündigen weil es so irwitzig
ist was denkt ihr wie viel die Fischerei
in der britischen Wirtschaft ausmacht
Ganze 0,1%. anders ausgedrückt es ging
hier um weniger als 1 Tausendstel der
britischen Wirtschaftsleistung weniger
als 1 tausendel und wie sieht es mit den
Finanzprodukten der Londoner City aus
dem Bankenviertel die machen rund 8% der
britischen Wirtschaftsleistung aus also
etwa 100 mal mehr ging es beim brexit
also wirklich um den Fisch oder ging es
nicht vor allem um das große Geld in
London denn die brexiteers sprachen zwar
viel und emotional über Fisch träumten
aber auch davon strenge
Finanzmarktregeln der EU loszu
werden mehr Liberalisierung das nannten
sie Singapur an der Themse Singapur ist
der wichtigste Finanzplatz Südostasiens
ein kleiner Stadtstaat und zugleich ein
globales Steuerparadies doch aus dem
superfinanzplatz London wurde
nichts im Gegenteil mit dem brexit
wanderten zeitweise bis zu 6 Milliarden
Euro an Finanzvolumen von London nach
Frankfurt Amsterdam Paris fast die
Hälfte des Londoner Aktienhandels brach
zwischenzeitlich weg und kürzlich liest
sogar der traditionell brexit
begeisterte Telegraph wissen dass der
legendäre Londoner Finanzplatz weiter
ins Hintertreffen
gerät bereits seit 2017 schrumpft die
Zahl der in London gelisteten Aktien
weil Firmen übernommen wurden oder
abgewandert sind oft nach Europa zu den
brexit heartlinern die die
wirtschaftliche Power von Singapur
damals auch für Großbritannien
beschworen gehört der konservative
Abgeordnete Jacob reiesmock ein Mann mit
einer Vergangenheit als Banker und
Hedgefond Manager der verteidigte im
britischen Parlament recht einsam den
brexit gegen den Vorwurf zum Disaster
für die Fischindustrie zu
werden selbst der unterhaussprecher
schien ihm den wahlkampfschlager mit den
Fischen nicht so ganz
abzukaufen populismusprinzip 1 das
können wir hier festhalten erfinde einen
Gegner der dir Böses will und wiederhole
die Geschichte wieder und wieder auch
wenn sie un Sinn ist bis die Leute sie
glauben damit sind wir bei
populismusprinzip
2 und dann war da noch die Sache mit dem
Bus ein schöner roter rechtsgelenkter
britischer Bus mit einer riesigen
Aufschrift wir senden jede Woche 350
Millionen britische Pfund nach Brüssel
lasst uns stattdessen damit den NHS
ausstatten der NHS das ist der National
Health Service also nationaler
Gesundheitsdienst ein weiteres verehrtes
Nationalsymbol im vereinigten Königreich
der Gesundheitsdienst garantiert jeder
in Großbritannien gemeldeten Person
medizinische Versorgung eine der großen
Errungenschaften des Wohlfahrtsstaates
für den sich die brexiteers ansonsten
nicht so stark gemacht haben ganz im
Gegenteil der Gesundheitsdienst NHS
beklagt unterfinanziert zu sein und
überfordert die brexit Verfechter also
entdeckten die englische
Krankenschwester die dringend mehr Hilfe
und Unterstützung braucht damit sie
anderen helfen kann leider kam bereits
während der Kampagne raus dass nach
Abzug des sogen Anten Briten Rabats und
aller euubventionen nur rund 160
Millionen pro Woche an die EU überwiesen
wurden man hatte sich um mehr als das
Doppelte um gut 200 Millionen Pfund
verrechnetge UPS und Premierminister
Boris Johnson fuhr mit einem Bus durch
das Land der mit einer Lüge lackiert
war
no yes es war einfach eine Lüge später
meinte Johnson das mit den 350 Millionen
Pfund sei ja genauso gar nicht gemeint
gewesen man habe die große Zahl einfach
mal auf den Bus geschrieben um Aufsehen
zu
[Applaus]
erregen und das ist ja Boris Johnsons
Clown Kompetenz es nicht ganz so genau
nehmen unvernünftig sein und bisschen
Spaß dabei
haben so richtig Boris Johnson neben was
jedenfalls unumstritten ist wie schlecht
der britische Gesundheitsdienst NHS
heute da steht mit dem Rücken zur Wand
das hat natürlich auch mit den
Nachwirkungen der schmerzhaften Pandemie
zu tun aber auch mit der Tatsache dass
ich die ohnehin bestehende Personalnot
seit dem brexit verschärft hat
Krankenschwestern aus Europa kommen
nicht mehr und seit bald zwei Jahren
streigt immer wieder das
Krankenhauspersonal und schiebt einen
Berg von fast 8 Millionen Arztterminen
und Operationen auf der NHS Warteliste
vor sich her das zweite populistische
Prinzip noch mal Lügen lohnt sich
falsche Fakten behaupten und wiederholen
bis die ihren Zweck erfüllt haben dann
kann man sie einfach wieder fallen
lassen und die dritte populistische
Strategie werde immer
[Musik]
radikaler und dabei funktioniert im
Kampf um wa nichts besser als die Angst
vor Migranten geschürt mit Plakaten wie
diesem 2016 während der brexitkampagne
die Botschaft massenhaft würden
geflüchtete über die südgrenzen der EU
bis nach Großbritannien vordringen und
noch kürzlich warnte die frühere
Innenministerin zellaa bravan selbst mit
Migrationshintergrund dramatisch vor
anschwellender Migration das war auf dem
Parteitag der Tories im
Herbst geflüchtete die in boten über den
Ärmelkanal kommen wollte bravman nach
Ruanda abschieben ein Bizer den
rishiunak der erste premier mit
Migrationshintergrund weiter verfolgt
obwohl die Gerichte das für
menschenrechtswiedrig halten und Rwanda
nicht für ein sicheres
Land die Zuwanderung auf Rekordhoch seit
dem brexit der das ja eigentlich
eindämmen sollte aus der EU kommen
allerdings 75% weniger als vorher die
Einwanderung aus nicht EU-Staaten hat
sich derweil um 300% erhöht dringend
benötigte Arbeitskräfte etwa für die
Pflege kommen jetzt nicht mehr aus Polen
sondern aus Indien oder Nigeria das
dritte Prinzip des Populismus noch mal
Ideen immer weiter radikalisieren das
scheint Politiker dazu zu zwingen bisher
gültige Grenzen zu verschieben etwa bei
demokratischen Werten und sogar die des
britischen Rechtsstaats die sich im Fall
der ab von Asylsuchenden nach Ruanda
zeigt die obersten Richter hatten ja
geurteilt das geht nicht weil es in
Ruanda für geflüchtete nicht sicher
ist das Gesetz der Tories heßt aber
sogar safety of R Sicherheit von Gesetz
die Regierung bleibt einfach dabei das
sei schließlich der Wille der Leute
verkündet Premierminister
sunak so scheint die Logik des brexit
bis heute zu funktionieren und zeigt wie
ein Land durch populistische Parolen
quasi in eine Falle Gerät der brexit
geht nicht wieder weg aber so richtig
glücklich macht der nicht mal seine
Anhänger
vergeben was man den Briten aber echt
lassen muss sie kommen auch in mieser
Lage irgendwie klar und können dabei
über sich selbst
lachen und ihr glaubt ihr dass
europäische Länder irgendwelche Lehren
aus der brexit Falle ziehen können und
wir rechtzeitig merken wenn Populisten
Fakten erfinden die dann auch an der
Realität scheitern schreibt es uns in
die Kommentare und abonniert gerne
unseren Kanal bis zum nächsten
Mal